So when you finish the first step,
the, the DNA extraction, you essentially have taken
our sample and like you said, sort of purified the DNA, from it gotten rid
of all the other stuff. The proteins, the other molecules that might be part of
cells and other kinds of contaminants. And you
pretty much just have a purified DNA product.
>> Exactly.
>> Now is, is that enough, already to do what you
want to do with it? Or what do you have to do next?
>> Not really.
It's common in many situations like this to
want to amplify the DNA. So you always want
to give yourself the best opportunity to sequence
what's in there. And the easiest way to do
that is to take the DNA you've got and amplify it, or copy it, as many times
as you can so that you just have
enough signal that you make it easy on yourself.
>> I see. So when you see say you, you're
amplifying or you're, you're making copies, I mean, you controlling
kind of how many copies you make. You just, you know, you are
making like, ten more, 20 more, you know, 100 more. How does that work?
>> Its not tightly controlled, but in essence,
at the end of the process, you end up
with 1000 fold enrichment of the DNA. So you
really do end up with a lot more DNA.
>> So do you end up with DNA left over? You know, after
you're done with the procedure, you actually have leftover DNA for, for people?
>> Sometimes we do.
but usually we store your DNA in its in the saliva form, so that we're
going back to the original copy. One
issue with amplification is that every time you
copy just like in DNA replication in
humans, there is a possibility for error. So,
those errors could compound if you keep copying
the copy, just like Xeroxing a Xerox, right.